okay so House of the dragon is about to
change the Game of Thrones and episode 9
has a lot going on with it in this video
we're going to be breaking down what
happens in the episode the Easter eggs
bug differences and also giving our
thoughts on what could happen in the
finale next week this has been a massive
season and I want to thank you for all
your support so far we recently got our
million subscriber plaque and it means
more to me than a seat on the Iron
Throne so I really appreciate the love
now the episode is called the green
Council and this term was coined by
Grand mace the monkey in the book the
name brings a lot with it as it of
course shows how this once and bias
Council has now been Twisted by Alison
into supporting her side whereas the
previous episodes all centered around
chapter 12 we are now in 13 which is
titled the dying of the Dragons the
blacks versus greens the war between the
houses took place between 129 and 131 AC
and the two years featured a lot of
deaths and the characters treating the
Iron Throne like it was a game of
musical chairs his period is known as
the dance of the Dragons but in the book
it said the phrase dying of the Dragons
is a lot more suitable the work is very
much a Chronicle of his time told To Us
by Witnesses the maesters it states that
due to them trying to add a poetic
player to the story that they changed it
to dance however it's an extremely
brutal period that's described as seeing
several of the last dragons being wiped
out the source material says it was a
war marked by stealth murder and
betrayal which we see from this opening
the death of viserys has massively
rocked the kingdom and due to his final
words Allison now believes she must
place aegon on the throne this is a
changer from the books as in those the
final speech by viserys never happened
as the Valerian steel dagger didn't
feature in the story at all I actually
prefer the way they've done it here
though with Alison actually believing
her BS instead of just doing it solely
for power like she did in the book now
he opened with a somber scene in which
we see the throne and rooms of King's
Landing completely desolate we hear a
single piano notes striking away
mimicking the sound of a bell when a
monarch died the bells of King's Landing
were typically run out to announce it
whether Allison holds these back so she
can plot and plan away and when the
source material a servant went to give
viserys a glass of hippocrats which is
when they found him dead they quickly
rushed to Alison and told her
immediately and he called together the
council the servant who found viserys
was immediately put into custody and
locked away so they couldn't discuss it
with anyone yeah they changed things up
slightly though so the servant goes to
her handmaid Natalya who then passes it
on to the queen though she eventually
does get jailed along with the others
she lights candles signaling the King
has passed away so that the underworld
can also put their plans in place the
book had them keeping viserys's death
quite for a week so that they could
organize everything to put aegon on the
throne here though it plays out slightly
differently with them being a bit more
respectful in the book his body was left
in the chambers with the door locked and
the Rats start to Feast on him
throughout the season we've seen a
season slowly got closer and closer them
appearing at the wedding before showing
up in his room the paragraph on him
reads A Day passed then another neither
acceptance nor silent sisters were
summoned into the bed chamber where King
viserys lay swollen and rotting nobels
rang Ravens flew but not to Dragonstone
they were instead sent to Old Town to
casterly rock to riverrun to haigon and
to many other Lords and nights whom
Queen Alison had caused the thing might
be sympathetic to her son some on the
council did want rhaenyra to be told but
Alison forbid it so that she couldn't
come back and claim her kingdom as for
the silent sisters we actually see them
appearing in this episode preparing
viserys's corpse last week they did the
same for baymund and they typically be
brought in to dress the body so that it
could have a funeral in line with the
house for example we see viserys being
wrapped in the same things that were
used on his wife Emma and also as child
Balon in episode one however vehman's
would have been dressed for a Burial at
Sea like Lena who who is also pretty
cremated too anyway Olivia Kirk delivers
a great performance on hearing the news
and is almost like there's some relief
along with a sorrow she feels she
immediately goes to Otto and obviously
she knows it's gonna be be difficult for
everyone to believe that she heard him
saying aegon should be put on the throne
but he didn't love and you'd bloody know
that if he'd been watching the videos
now the Valerian steel dagger gets pasta
egg on come the end of the episode and
this explains how the prophecy didn't
then get passed on from King to King
like it had been before there's lots of
things that happened down the line but I
suspect this will just get lost a time
with raniera being unable to show her
Offspring the words because she doesn't
possess the blade if you're wondering
where anira and Damon are in this
episode then you might remember that
last time that they said they were going
to Dragonstone there's a big event
possibly coming in Rainier's life next
week that we'll talk about in the book
spoiler section at the end of the video
I think it was a risky move just
focusing on the greens but personally I
like the choice but they're very much
showing how much conspiring and betrayal
that there was in the Kingdom ranero
being detached from this really splits
the sides and will make the audience
root for her even more because we've
seen firsthand how many people are
working against her I read a couple of
complaints from Team Green saying that
the show painter and era out as an Angel
when she really wasn't but I think that
kind of character development will be
reserved for season two now this video
is sponsored by established titles a
gift that lets you become like your
favorite Lord a lady in House of the
Dragon did you know there's a
traditional Scottish custom to have
landowners referred to as a lord lady or
a lad that's why I was super interested
in this project which allows you to get
at least one square foot of dedicated
land in Edelson Scotland it's also a
great way to help out the environment as
established titles will plant one tree
with every single order they work with
Charities like one tree planet and trees
for the future to help with
reforestation efforts so if you pick up
a plot you can refer to yourself as a
lord whilst helping to preserve the
picturesque Woodlands of Scotland now
there also comes a bit of an ego boost
on top of all this environmental stuff
because you're now a lord ladder a lady
you can officially change your name on
things like credit cards plane tickets
your dating profile whatever you want to
do as you can see here they give you an
official certificate and also details
the exact location of your unique plot
number on top of this established titles
have also told me that the first 200
people who use my link below will be
placed within walking distance from my
plot depending on how many of you want
to become a lord lady a LED we can build
our unique heavy spoil item Kingdom
together you can be like Lord Kevin
spoilers you punk I'll see you jump
established titles is actually running a
massive early Black Friday sale right
now plus if you use the code heavy
spoilers you get an additional 10 off go
to establishtitles.com heavy spoilers to
get your gift and help support the
channel makes for a great last minute
gift you can get yourself involved in
all the house of the Dragons drama so
definitely go check it out in the
description below thanks from here we
jump to the council and Thailand
Lannister ends up cracking this one what
is it that could not have waited an hour
was Dawn invaded
don't exist in the Southlands of
Westeros and it's a place that we
visited in Game of Thrones the king is
dead though Elvis has left the building
and now they have to decide what to do
Alison has actually painted out as being
very different to how she is in the book
with her almost being reluctant
overdoing this whole thing she's shocked
to learn others on the council have
planned aegon will succeed his father
and it turns out that both Otto and
Thailand have wanted this for a long
time there's a shot towards the end that
I absolutely love where I could see him
realizing the day he's waited on has
finally come it's finally materializing
before his very eyes and the guy just
seems so happy that it's all coming
together now instantly Lord beesberry
wants to shut this conversation down
there's discussion of the Lords that
already tore allegiance to an era in
episode 1. this happened in 105 AC and
the show is a line that someone touches
upon what appears in the book hundreds
of Lords and landed nights small fealty
to the person 20 years ago must have
been out dead now the source material
says to Thailand pointed out that many
of the Lords had sworn to defend the
succession of Princess rhaenyra were
long dead it's been 24 years he said I
myself swore no such oath I was a child
at a time in the work Orwell originally
up in the meeting by reviewing the
customary tasks and procedures with the
death of a king But Otto cut him off and
said all this must needs weight until
the question of succession is settled
until such a time as our new king is
crowned notice that word King and
someone quickly replied saying until our
new Queen is crowned this line later
gets played upon by Udo when he says the
door remains shut until we finish our
business bees Brie doesn't bees leave it
and he even accuses someone of murdering
viserys in his sleep this is something
that we've touched upon in other videos
and it's one big thing
so in the book there was talk about how
Alison may have poisoned viserys and
that he played a big part last episode
Damon ended up sniffing it suspiciously
afterwards and later on Otto offered it
to viserys however he turned this down
and he managed to regain his strength at
the point that he went to the throne
room and also held his last supper side
note this was obviously playing on the
last supper from the Bible too anyway
the tea was then given to him that night
and no I don't I don't think Alison
killed him there probably will always be
people who talk about how she could have
due to her reaction over the corpse
though I don't think it's the case and
he seems genuinely good at that he's
gone anyway that's enough dude I'm just
a theory I only hear people talking [ __ ]
about it don't kick off you idiot of you
a Lord beesbury's Death plays out in
several different ways in the book
depending on which account you listen to
as always there's slightly different
sources over what happened but they all
end in his death Grand Mesa always said
that Lord beesbury was seized at the
door by the command of Sir or Hightower
and then escorted to the dungeons yeah
he was confined to a black cell and he
apparently died of a chill whilst
awaiting trial septon Eustis gets it the
closest though as we see how he's killed
by Kristen in the council room the work
describes him as opening his throat with
a dagger whereas here he smashes his
head like it's the like button either
way this is classed as the first blood
that was drawn during the dance of the
Dragons the book later states that all
will would later claim that he said a
lot of things at beesbury did and this
was so he could come out looking good
the Lannister bloody title and Lana
Stallard he also ends up taking over as
the master of coin in the wake of his
death Harold westerling immediately
draws his sword and as episode 1 showed
he's very loyal to an Era he instantly
recognizes what this has turned into and
vacates his position this is similar to
how barrist and salmi would quit after
the death of Robert Baratheon who as we
know thinks everyone's a bloody bastard
now he does this in the wake of Otto
ordering him to take his Knights to
Dragonstone in order to kill rhaenyra
with him being out Kristin gets put in
as the Lord Commander which will mean
that Alison has someone lost to her
heading up the king's God however the
Burke at the events play out differently
with westerling dying in 112 AC almost
20 years before the death of viserys
Kristen still got to the same place but
he wasn't used as a weapon like what
Alison does here add some drama to it
and the plans to kill runera are put in
place due to knowing that she won't bend
the knee Alison is the one who ends up
saving her and she refuses to let them
go ahead with the assassination of her
old friend last episode they seemed to
bury the hatchet and if we're talking
about Karma this could be something that
saves Alison in the end typically what
goes around comes around in Game of
Thrones and if we look at this having
this side to it then it might be what
saves her in some way Laris hangs around
like a bad smell at points but in the
source material he was invited to the
council he actually sliced his hand open
and influenced the others into taking a
Blood Oath and though he gets some body
fluid on his hand later it's not really
the same thing now we go to Helena
sewing together a spider her mother had
her studying in insects instead of
dragons and this played in into the
funeral episode in which she too looked
over a bug she once more drops this line
which calls back to last week when she
said the same thing
this is likely referring to the dragon
that pops about the end of the episode
it comes from the boards under the
dragon pit and likely seems to be that
however it might be something else but
it's such a big spoiler that I'm gonna
save it for the end of the video so
stick around chump see you chump now
it's also important to bear in mind that
we see her two twin children here in
joharis and johera in the book they were
taken to viserys on the morning he died
and he told them the stories of their
names and the great king jaharis anyway
we could have crossed to arik Argyle who
was supposed to be aegon slow protector
we get to learn why he's now just
reduced to quiet quitting and the
reasoning behind why he doesn't protect
aegon similar to howranera Snuka in
episode 4 we discover that aegon has
used the secret passages in order to
leave the red keep now Eric and Eric
Cargill are identical twins who end up
supporting opposite sides to each other
they briefly appeared in the series so
far with one advice in Queen Alison last
week in the red keep the Twins were
identical and in the show they're going
to be played by Luke Titan saw
tinsel
anyway both Knights and bought an
attorney that was shown in episode 1 and
the pair were knocked off their horses
by Sir Christian Cole Eric was also the
knight in the book who said that he
found Damon and raniero in bed together
and this slowly started to spread that
rumor throughout the kingdom I Eric
ended up going with the greens and Tito
his brother being on the opposite side
he was chosen opposes him for Missions
down the line elsewhere Anis is locked
in her Chambers and she relies on Eric
saving her later on Kristen 2 is given
the same Mission by Alison and we see
Eamonn sitting in front of a fire this
brought back a lot of imagery to me of
when Damon sat in front of one at the
end of episode 2 and I love how they're
showing how the pair marijuana are there
as the investigation gets further along
we also discovered that egg on his
father the son which could massively
mess up the line of succession now
aegon's bastards are mentioned in the
book alongside the three children that
he had with Helena these were malor and
the twins to Harris and yahera as for
the bass sorry I keep calling Ambassador
I sound like Robert Baratheon you're
bloody bastard now as for the bastards
the book reads a wife and children did
little to curb the carnal appetites of
Prince egg on the Elder if mushroom is
to be believed he followed two bastard
children the same year as the twins a
boy on a girl who's Maiden Hood he won
at an auction on the street of sulk and
a girl by one of his mother's
maidservants the former is the one that
we meet in the episode and the street of
silk was basically a red light district
that existed in King's Landing Damon
frequented a lot too and it's where he
gave his effort a speech back in episode
1. now it is possible that the former is
also born because the plan T from last
week was sabotaged the servant who gave
it to the queen was revealed to be a
mazarian informant and therefore it is
possible that she prepared the drink
without putting this ingredient in it
this would mean that the child could
still be born and it may end up popping
up in season two now it turns out aegon
took Eamon there when he was 13 and
though there's no mention of this in the
book aegon is described as going there a
lot the book also goes into how aegon
was found differently to what happens in
the entry they say that Kristen found
him in a flea bottom rap here with a
girl who couldn't have been more than
12. the book then goes on to say though
the good septum emits Prince aegon was
with a paramour when he was found he
insists the girl was a daughter of a
wealthy Trader and well cared for
besides moreover the prince at first
refused to be part of his mother's plan
my sister is the heir not me he says in
eustis's account what sort of brother
steals his sister's Birthright only when
sir Kristen convinced him that the
princess must surely execute him and his
brothers should on the crown dead egg on
Weber while study true Targaryen yet
lives no strong can ever hope to sit on
the Iron Throne Colt said renera has no
choice but to take your heads if she
wishes her bastards to rule after her it
was this and only this that persuaded
aegon to accept the crown that the small
Council was offering now eventually they
come across him in the sept which isn't
the kind of place he'd expect to find
him so it's the perfect hiding spot in
the throne room Otto asks for the Lords
to break their oats in order to side
with aegon here we see Lord Caswell who
is one of raniera's loyalist supporters
he greeted her as she climbed the stairs
with Geoffrey and also showed up last
week he fakes being loyal to aegon but
secretly he wants to head off like
Raymond unfortunately he's caught and
the work tells us that he's beheaded but
here he ends up being hanged cut across
to the aforementioned plea bottom rap
hit and we see the teeth of children
being looked at before they're tossed
into the arena the work also mentions
that aegon was found with two gooder
Snipes with wild teeth that were biting
and tearing at each other just for his
Amusement now though he's not here and
Eric tells his brother this kind of
shows who the king truly is he wants him
to come with him to the blacks but alas
they end up falling apart now speaking
of going to the blacks we see Caswell
moving through the court which has black
and red soldiers in it last week Raymond
was brought in by the Hightower ones in
this place is Handy show he chose a
place loyal to an Era to try and make a
move one of miseria's servants goes to
Eric and Eric and we hear the nickname
of the White Worm could a cross to
viserys being prepared and we see the
crown being placed onto his body to bear
with him in the book she ordered for it
to be put in a vault but a servant stole
it and then ran off with it if you watch
the trailer 50 times like I have then
you'll you'll know that this might not
be the last time we see it but I won't
spot I've already [ __ ] spoiled it
anyway rainis is still in a cell and
Alison goes to her and asks her to join
her side Ray nice mirrors Ranier Beyond
just her name and similar to her she was
the next in line but this was taken away
with a man getting the throne it's sort
of like poetry they rhyme and Alison
even admits that rainy should have been
Queen however she also clearly knows the
kind of monster that egg on is and for
some reason still wants to prop him on
the throne Alison says that if Bernice
puts her dragons on the green side then
renira will hesitate to strike and this
very much set up the statement that she
does at the end in the ceremony Otto
meets with miserie who reveals she's got
leaks like Reddit before the She-Hulk
finale and mizeria is a tragic figure
who in the book actually did fall
pregnant to Damon however she lost it
during a storm at sea because viserys
forced the pair to split up and in the
end she had to travel away from Westeros
she would give up the location of aegon
but she wants to change things in the
area including the fighting pits that
involve the children Sonia Mizuno is a
great actress and check out the dance
moves in ex machina to show how she can
shake things up now whether Otto changes
things in art remains to be seen and him
potentially not doing this could set up
the blood and cheese storyline that
we'll talk about later on aegon is
brought out and this separates the twins
Eamonn and Kristen have tracked them
down and fight fight fight fight now
aegon doesn't want to rule and he even
talks about getting about and sailing
away this is summer Delano who would
have sat on the throne beside raniera
but instead he fled and actually managed
to get a happy ending Alison confronts
Otto and very much blames him for trying
to install aegon much in the same way
that he installed her Alice in order's
terms are sent to an Era instead of the
assassins and she makes egg on take egg
on the conqueror's crown and carry a
sword blackfyre now egg on the
conqueror's crown brings a lot with it
saras's Crown was previously owned by
Joe Harris and the pair were both kings
that sort of piece juxtaposing this
aegon's Crown was what he used in his
Conquest to take six of the Seven
Kingdoms and it's normally been worn by
Kings who seek out domination maegor the
crew also done there before egg on II
did and it carries Way Beyond simply
being a headpiece as different accounts
over what it's actually made of with
some saying it's Valerian steel whilst
others say that it's iron this was
originally adorned with rubies which are
missing here but if you look closely you
can see the indentation for them there's
also lots of symbolism to this being
placed on a green cushion this is of
course the color of the high towers and
the crown now sitting on this shows who
now has control of the realm one of the
few images in the books depicts Kristen
Cole placing this on eggen's head which
is something that we also get in this
scene Eamon looks over it and there's a
lot going on with his face much like
Damon he did have some deep rooted
desires to rule and we might explore
what happens with this in future
episodes at one point in the book he
does end up wearing it very briefly and
he says that it looks much better on him
than it does on his brother he's clearly
meant to mirror the character and not
only is his brother now the king but he
also walks the streets of King's Landing
in a herd in order to hide his hair now
earlier in episode he brought up how
he's more fitting in The King and I
wonder if they're going to add some
division between the two would be wild
if we had a civil war within a Civil War
and this civil warception could add even
more drama to the show like The Riddler
appearing in the room Lara's shows have
been Alison's looking as creepy as ever
he tells her about my zarya whilst we
see Quentin Tarantino's favorite scene
in the episode playing out before our
very eyes I don't know about giving the
guy with a bad foot a foot fetish um
it's a bit on the nose which I don't
know and the guy starts banging his sept
in and again Alison is just being used
to get met off time for a joke what's
Lara's clubfoot's favorite place to hang
out clubfoot
[Music]
he reveals Talia and suggests killing my
zarya which is gonna have major
repercussions down the line it's all
tying into that spoiler section at the
end potentially and stick around yet
stick around if you want to ruin it for
yourself now Eric rescues rhaenys and
they go past the black dread skull it
stands as a monument to viserys's dragon
and he never took one after its ball
rainy spouses for a moment to look at it
and I believe they exit the red keep
using the same passage that reniro did
in episode 4. you watch a burning
building that's likely Larissa's minions
killing the Spy so that the kingdom is
now clear cut to a parchment that gets
rolled out and I paused this and read it
through so you don't have to it
constantly mentions the seven as in fate
of the seven and the Seven Kingdoms
aegon II is brought up too and we see
this tactic being brought into our own
politics as well Boris Johnson was often
referred to as being like Churchill and
Liz trust is often mentioned as being
the same as Margaret Thatcher however
unlike egg on the Conqueror the second
of his name doesn't want to rule and
he's come completely pathetic even
brings up how his dad didn't love him
which was touched upon last week this
point he's given the dagger but the
truth of this is meaningless because
aegon doesn't know what it foretells
it's now just an ornament a hollow
symbol of royalty much like how this
whole charade is once more Alison tries
to impress on him that he can't kill
rhaenyra but he interrupts this with
this line do you love me
Alison's reaction here gives a lot away
and again it's Olivia Cook completely
nailing the material she makes a joke
out of the situation but subtly shakes
her head giving us the clear answer that
she's thinking no however she does throw
herself in front of the dragon come the
end of the episode and I'm gonna need a
YouTube body language expert to come in
and break this down because I feel like
she's saying no rainis wanted to go to
the Dragon's pit and he sees him in when
the crowds start to huddle towards it
this is where the coronation was held in
the book but they do alter some major
things in the source material against
Dragon Sunfire was unveiled at the
public here and he wrote on the back of
it as if Lou three times around the
location the buck can often be seen as
propaganda and therefore you can see how
they twist This Disaster into something
more positive you might also notice the
Targaryen symbol behind Alison is now
gold instead of red and this was changed
during aegon's rule in order to mimic
Sunfire the crowd react really well to
egg on being crowned I think this makes
him start to enjoy being in the role
Georgia R Martin's work is often seen as
being a criticism of the monarchy and
how stupid it is to let people rule due
to their bloodline there's also that
stuff where they're apparently chosen by
God and how stupid it is is definitely
the case here we all know aegon
shouldn't be ruling but people have
brought him in and now he's very much
part of the system the crowd shares and
aegon draws the conqueror's sword
finally realizing he has power of the
entire realm Auto Lux is proud as my
granite was when I took over the spoiler
game but Alison sadly has regret in her
eyes the chairs quickly turned to
screams and the celebrations are cut
short byronissa's Dragon named after one
of the old gods of Valeria she wrecks
the entire place and this could explain
why it fell into disrepair though this
also happened due to the dragons dying
out come the end of Game of Thrones it
was a shell of its former self she could
kill them all at this point but instead
she makes it clear to not with her
family I would have went dracaryus on
the whole lot but viserys's children are
still there and she sees her mother as
soon protecting her child Alison was of
course desperate to have her on her side
but what a badass way to end off this
episode gave me chills watching her fly
away and yeah that final scene is very
haunting similar to ranera she was
supposed to be the queen but she had
this taken away from her because to
Harris wanted a male to rule rainy sees
history repeating itself and you know
how granddaughter is being betrothed to
the strong sorry targaryens she rightly
sides with them this ending very much
serves as a warning of Harry niece can
bring it all crashing down if she wants
to it's pretty much saying she could
have killed them if she wanted to but
she let them live because they don't
have the power that she does she warns
them they have a lot of dragons and not
to go against them unless she wants to
see defeat like Lara strong
oh brother this guy stinks now that
wraps up the penultimate episode and it
very much feels like they come before
the storm I love how much chaos the
realm has been thrown into and though
our own passing of the Monarch was a lot
more straightforward it's nice seeing
the chaos that could have come from this
the episode is a perfect example of how
ugly the high Towers were and how they
do anything in their quest for power I
love the added Dimension that wasn't in
the books too which has alicent
misinterpreting viserys's final words
this will now push her even further and
all in all it's going to cause a major
Civil War that's going to make for some
really gripping TV it's crazy how much
character growth we've seen since
episode 1 and going back to that Alison
seems like a completely different person
even though her son doesn't want to be
the king she's forced him to live out
this ambition that was very much forced
on her by her father lots of subtext
with it and this was another great
episode now as for the spoilers I think
next week's gonna have some major events
in it I'm gonna give you a heads up to
back out if you don't want to know as it
could ruin the ending of this series
thanks for sticking with me this far
into the video and hopefully I'll see
you next week now raniera likely faces
two major losses next week the first
comes in the form of her son luceris who
is killed by Eamonn after he demands an
eye from him when the Ravens were sent
out for help storms then became a
priority in this Alison insisted Eamon
go himself he traveled out there on the
back of agar and offered to marry one of
Lord boris's daughters useris arrived
not long after and he couldn't do the
same thing as he was already betrothed
to his cousin Eamonn ended up following
him after he was taunted by one of
boris's daughters that he didn't pick
and he ended up killing Luke Damon then
promised her a son for his son and this
could tie into the Beast beneath the
board's prophecy this has popped up
twice now so I'm guessing it's very very
important like I said it could be the
dragon but there could be more to it
Damon goes to Missouri yet and asks her
to kill one of aegon's children and she
sends into assassins called blood and
cheese they end up using the secret
passages to infiltrate the red keep and
perhaps the prophecy being mentioned by
Wise It's referring to these two
different events it might be rich and
mazaria is known as the White Worm so
that covers the Beast bit and the
Assassins sneaking in could refer to
them being beneath the boards and back
with renira she goes into labor and
during this she discovers that the
throne's been stolen from her this
causes immense stress on her body and
for days she wails going through the
horrendous birth she screams monster at
the child and then when it's born it
comes out deformed and carrying a
dragon's tail Runner says that Alison
stole her child and the throne from her
in one foul swoop I can't see this being
how they end this series with this
becoming the final nail in the coffin
that makes runira realize she can't
negotiate with the greens after this the
counter of the blacks is created to
combat the other side and that season 2
is gonna leave me looking like baserus
drained dead inside and just waiting for
it all to be over so that's the video
and obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts in what you and has seen the
finale we are in competition right now
and giving away three copies of top gun
Maverick on the 15th of November and all
you had to do beyond the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe the notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode you pick the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now
save that to you message me on Twitter
at heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch make sure you check out
our breakdown rings of power which will
be linked on screen right now we
discussed the finale in all its detail
so definitely head over there right
after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
poor I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]